US Surgeon General dr. Jerome Adams is a
member of the White House coronavirus
task force and he joins us from
Washington dr. Adams good morning to you
thank you for being here good morning on
this program on Monday you warned
Americans that it was gonna be a bad
week and that proved to be true there
was nearly a tenfold increase in the
number of official cases of corona virus
can you say now on Friday that the worst
is still yet to come well it's important
for people to know that everyone's curve
is going to be different New York is
going to look different than Boise Idaho
or Jackson Mississippi or New Orleans
and we know that this week was a
particularly bad week for New York the
good news is that China South Korea are
reopening Italy looks like deaths and
cases are going down and in Washington
and you heard the governor of New York
actually say yesterday that their cases
have actually leveled off in terms of
new cases day by day so we know that we
can get through this as it definitely we
can get through this but but dr. Adams
as a country should Americans gird
themselves for what's ahead is the worst
of this still ahead of us well again it
depends on where you are we're hopeful
that next week New York will start to
come down because again their cases have
started to level off and that's because
they've been aggressive about their
mitigation efforts we see that now that
the places that have been aggressive
about staying at home about keeping
under groups of 10 have been successful
but we also see hotspots like Detroit
like Chicago like New Orleans that will
have a worst week next week than what
they had this week so again as Tony
Falchi said the virus and the local
community are going to determine the
timeline it's not going to be us from
Washington DC people need to follow
their data they need to make the right
decisions based on what their data is
telling them and the good news here is
that we've seen testing increase
significantly we're approaching a
million tests we're trying to get people
the data so that they can make informed
decisions about where they are on their
timeline and what they should be doing
yep
dr. Adams let's talk about ventilators
for just a second you know doctors and
nurses around the country are saying
hello government we need ventilators we
need ventilators now but President Trump
seems to have a different take on that I
want you to hear what he said last night
and get your response to that but I have
a feeling that a lot of the numbers that
are being said in some areas are just
they're going to be I don't believe you
need 40,000 or 30,000 ventilators you
know you going to major hospitals
sometimes they'll have two ventilators
and now all of a sudden they're saying
can we order 30,000 ventilators dr.
Adams the president Chara knowledge has
no medical training yet he continues to
question the advice from the medical
experts and professionals is that
frustrating to you
well you mentioned ventilators and dr.
Burke said this when you look at some of
the projections out there they're based
on worst-case scenarios and doing
something I heard a reporter yelling at
Peter Navarro yesterday where is a
million ventilators a million
ventilators for you the United States
would mean one in 300 people in this
country were on a ventilator at once
there is nowhere in the world where
we've seen that type of spread of
coronavirus not even close and so some
of these projections are way off but we
are leaning into supply I was on a
meeting with the American Society of
Anesthesiologists last week and they've
identified 70,000 ventilators that are
in communities right now that can be
true Cuomo asked for ventilators he gave
very specific numbers do you think he
doesn't know what he's talking about
when it comes to this issue when he's on
constant contact with New York the top
New York hospitals by the way well I
think that if you I don't think that's a
fair question and I think that if you
talk to experts dr. Falchi dr. Burks and
others the models and in many cases are
way off in the new york city we actually
have people on the ground who have told
us that there are a thousand ventilators
sitting in a warehouse right now and
haven't been used you heard Governor
Cuomo yesterday say look we actually
have resources they're just mismatched
and so we sent a team a FEMA team to
help New York City make sure the
resources are getting to where they need
I talk to people in western New York who
said they're furlough and nurses and
hospitals in western New York State and
while people in New York City are
suffering we need to make sure we get
the right resources to the right people
and that's what we're committed to do oh
yeah please with the government's
response dr. Adams based on what you're
saying to us right now you pleased with
how things are going well pleased is I
don't think a fair word because gosh
there are people dying my colleagues out
there suffering I'm not pleased with the
with with the entirety of the response
because it takes state and federal and
people come together I take out pleased
are you satisfied pardon are you
satisfied with how things are going I'm
not gonna be satisfied until we get till
the to the end of this and we see
cooperation at every level and we see
health care workers getting what they
need dr. Adams you mentioned hotspots
and at the same time the administration
is putting out a letter to Governor
saying they may have tears for risk
different areas of the country would
open others would not given the lack of
testing in many areas and given that one
patient moving from one hotspot to a non
hotspot can ignite a whole new outbreak
how realistic is it really to have those
tears how you gonna do that I'm gonna be
bans on movement well you heard dr.
Burks say yesterday that 19 out of our
50 states about 40 percent of the
population of our country has been doing
surveillance testing and has shown
consistently low rates of spread of
coronavirus we also know that the local
authorities are the ones who make those
decisions I used to run a state the
Health Department for a State Health
Department for three years we want to
get people the tools they need to make
the right decisions and right now there
are some places that are going to be New
York City there are other places that
are going to see low spread and we want
them to have the the information to make
the right decisions and we're not going
to make those decisions from DC we're
going to give them the tools the advice
the data and it's going to be up to them
to decide what they do thank you very
much dr. Adams for being with us